et bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale télé
championnat du monde d'échecs allende
topaloff
aujourd'hui nous recevons le maître fide
et jean-jacques rabeyrin bonjour le lac
bonjour c'est fun alors toujours pas
rien toujours parisien
alors je crois que c'est à nous de nous
donner c'est que tu vois des fois
cramique à paris oui je dois pas inviter
très très loin de chez lui puisque je
croise très souvent quand je fais mes
courses
il habite dans mon quartier voilà parce
qu'il en fait ils travaillent
à moitié en fait en russie aux familles
il partage son temps entre moscou et
paris moi c'est ça je ne sais pas mais
il est lié parfois par il est parfois
pareil ça c'est sûr d'accord alors tu
suis évidemment ce match bien entendu un
topaloff alors est-ce que tu le suis
parce que quand tu as un travail en
dehors des échecs
c'est vrai que l'ailé des championnats
du monde à mai au mexique c'était
hésitez plus sympa parce que ça les
parties avaient lieu le soir vers 20
heures quand on sort de travail ouais
voilà c'est plus dur mais bien sûr le
soir quand je rentre chez moi mes autres
partis n'ont pas le dire je peux pas non
plus n'a pas le temps on a un travail
très prenant alors tu tu suis ce match
est-ce que tu as un favori donc en
trouver entre les deux joueurs
alors mon favori de coeur c'est un an
j'ai toujours aimé son style oui bon je
dois vous ici jamais donner un pronostic
avant le début du match j'aurais dit je
pensais qu'ils auraient pas de match et
au octobre alors gagné très facilement
pourquoi ça pourtant au niveau du
classement il ya très peu d'écart bon
parce que quelque part de jeu santé
topalov plus avec les plus la grinta l'
envie de gagner qui ferait la différence
et puis joue chez lui il peut être aussi
parce qu'il joue chez lui et que
cramique ces derniers ont annoncé
derniers temps n'a pas été très
convaincant dans les tournois il a fait
il était reçu comme un héros qu'il est
en inde il a fait à beaucoup de l a fait
beaucoup de beaucoup de manifestations
il ya un côté quelque part il a tout
gagné il y as qui l'a encore prouvé ce
qui là encore est ce qu'il ya un lien à
la rage de vaincre mais je pensais que
cela suffirait pas comparé aux
comparaisons celle de de topalov la
première partie de manière très fait
peur que ça devrait vous fait peur parce
que je pensais que ça confirmer ce que
oui oui moi aussi j'ai vu c'est vrai çà
et là il a pris davantage
alors pas forcément dans la préparation
même si c'est souvent lui qui a sorti
des nouveautés pas forcément dans leur
préparation en deuxième partie on a bien
vu
il gagne mais certaines l'ouverture je
sais pas trop ce qu'il a je pense qu'il
n'a pas grand chose à rennes il a réussi
à poser de gros problèmes quand même un
taux plafond mais il a vraiment dominé
topalov dans le milieu de jeu mais je
pensais plus plus vraiment la qualité de
jeu à trensacq que la préparation est
même évoqué pour le moment il a éliminé
en tête qu'on verra donc là
effectivement on est à la cinquième
partie humaine y mène 2 1 avant cette
partie
deux victoires à une les deux blancs en
fait les annuler avec les noirs et là
donc de nouveau et là les noirs donc une
occasion pour topalov pourquoi pas
d'essayer de revenir au score
il faut savoir avoir rappelé quand même
que le match se déroule en 12 parties
donc il faut quand même atteindre
six et demi ça peut aller a quand même
assez assez vite donc il faut que
topalov essaie de coller car déjà
n'augmentent pas et si possible
maintenant de le réduire
mauvais début de match pour topalov
finalement peut-être que ce but d'entrée
en quelque sorte un presque un but
cette première partie finale l'udsr
puisqu'il s'est peut-être relâché en
fait après ses deux victoires
je ne sais pas si avec la deuxième
partie est curieux soit yayi a fait
beaucoup d'imprécisions la troisième
la troisième qui va ressembler qui
ressemble on va voir ses deux parties
alors juste un compte juste avant lui
que tu vas nous rappeler à tous les
maîtres fidh et oui donc c'est juste en
fait il ya trois titres internationaux
qui sont maître fide maître
international puis grand maître
international et donc mettre au filet ça
représente à peu près de 2300 euros
c'est exactement là où je crois qu'il y
en a d'autres qui ont été créés depuis
mai en france vraiment personnel mais en
fait ces trois titres essentiels courait
en gros mais trop fit c'est un peu
aspirants m en fait en gros c'est un le
niveau à peu près des meilleurs amateurs
on peut dire il ya quelques amateurs qui
sont m me sont pas très nombreux oui
mais c'est alors c'est le titre ça c'est
le plus petit robert qui compte pour
faire de m
des normes de maître international oui
tous ces joueurs sont considérés comme
titre et donc voilà donc on a un titre
et parisienne tout venant quelques la
joue en fait on joue juste en dehors de
paris à linselles un mécène d'accord
avec une équipe et ce uniquement
d'amateurs
ce qui à leur tour national ce qui est
rare que des amateurs de challenge et
toujours quelques quelques professions y
avait aussi quelques championnats de
france championnat je joue assez peu et
il essaie d'alléger fait parfois le
championnat de paris parfois chapelle à
paris voilà ça qui dure quelques un
grand tournoi d'ailleurs un conduit très
très beau tournoi vous invite à jouer
effectivement c'est un beau tour bien
organisés en général et qui se déroule
début juillet à paris avec souvent près
de 600 joueurs pas le bien pendant une
semaine
oui je pense que le record je crois
qu'ils sont amis
me semble donc très beau tournoi ce
championnat de paris international donc
on y va pour ce championnat du monde
alan topalov ici topalov à les blancs on
est dans la cinquième partie il est mené
au score 2 victoires à 1
ces partis des quatre donc là n'en fait
reprend des 5 c'est à dire que la
première partie qu'il a perdu il avait
joué une grande fête c'est à dire on va
vous rappeler que la grogne fel il avait
joué son cas magnifique il a joué j'ai
six pour mettre son fou angers7
et entre temps il a joué des cinq ça
c'était là grünfeld mais quand on joue
des scènes tout de suite on peut pas
vraiment rentré dans une brune fais donc
après ces quatre ânes on avait joué dans
la troisième partie c6 et il reprend ce
même coup dans la cinquième en gênant on
change pas une formule qui gagne 1 min
il a donné l'impression de légaliser
cette fin de nuit des dialyses entre
autres problèmes dans la troisième
alors vous rappelle qu'en championnat du
monde bon mais il ya très peu de
victoires de la part des noirs ça arrive
mais c'est rare et que faire nul avec
les noirs c'est un bon score et ont des
champions s'en contente en essayant de
gagner avec les blancs moutons plus
qu'il me en plus s'ils mènent donc
effectivement une nulle avec les noirs
lui permet de maintenir son avantage et
et de jouer avec les blancs l'esprit
serein alors on continue donc cavalier
f3 de la part de topalov cabaye f6
normal qu'à laisser trois ans suis pour
l'instant
puis on prend ces 4 je vous invite
évident à revoir là est le commentaire
de la troisième partie qu'on a pu
analyser sur des gones halle avec
aurélie dacalor et puis je vous invite à
revoir
ces deux partis là puisque c'est à peu
près les mêmes jusqu'à ce qu'on dévie ce
qu'on verra plus tard après peut on
penser 4 à 4 donc on peut dire oui
france et cassis joue une vraie cela
valoir que contradictoires il a joué
surtout des semis cela ben oui il allait
pas pris ils prenaient plus j'avais joué
beaucoup de parties avec le 6 way he
amicale et joyeuse si c'est ça dont un
en finlande avait joué si oui à face à
lille joue la vraie cela on l'a vu dans
la troisième partie différée une chose
dans cette partie voilà il prend il
prend l'option c4 donc à quatre ça c'est
pour empêcher la la défense du pion
sépare b5 évidemment voilà donc on fait
à 4 et la foule zinc pour repêcher le
cadre tout de suite voilà contrôle
academy 6 voilà donc la la suite
pareil que dans la troisième cavalier
seul alors l'idée des blancs fait savoir
en kabylie centrale ça c'est une chose
mais c'est de jouer f3 f4 pour chasser
ce fou et avoir deux pions centraux
voilà donc une possibilité de six donc
ça tout ça s'est relativement normale et
la c5
alors voilà donc tu alors tu me dis ici
alors donc là ça c'est le coup comme
dans la troisième
et il ya aussi ce coup qui est possible
foulée carlos coûts qui existent aussi
qui qui plus est est rock'n'roll car il
implique forcément sacrifice d'une pièce
en général alors pourquoi une sacrifice
des pierres en général avec 4 apple à
4,4 en sacrifice et ça on prend 1,4 avec
le fou exactement et après prise qui
avait les preuves 4 avec une double idée
c'est alors qu'un on fait ici une menace
de prendre ces trois puis deux saliver
aussi la dame qui peut éventuellement
venir peut-être en h4 voir prendre des
quatre souvent quand même prendre dans
des cas à protéger on est obligés de
mettre le fond des deux
mais le fou et on a déjà pris trois
pions pour la pièce donc ça peut être
intéressant
donc là il choisit pas donc ils
choisissaient 5 comme dans la troisième
partie
ces cinq temps que quatre classiques
donc la foulée 6 alors le noir aurait pu
aussi choisir de prendre d'abord en et
cas puisque ça attaque le câble et c3
est sans doute le cavalier bouchonnant
b5 sans doute quelque chose comme ça
alors non je oui donc c'est une
possibilité donc en général
alors c'est un petit peu piégeux entre
guillemets parce que ça ça existe en ga
en prof ou directement on prend le fou
quand même
et alors là horreur on s'aperçoit qu'on
ne peut pas prendre les cavaliers parce
que sur six ont procuré à bien sûr il ya
d'un point d'un programme
roy prend et 10.7 bravo bien vu avec
fourchette donc échec au roi et une fois
que l'on aura à bouger il ya la tour est
prise c'est une fourchette classique de
très belle facture donc s'écrire des
cats ça peut paraître c'est qu'on ait
quatre ça peut paraître bizarre parce
qu'ils ont très peu probable ça qu'on a
perdu une pièce si on est on voit qu'on
ne peut pas là donc on ne peut pas on
peut pas reprendre à cause de cette
variante donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
avec les noirs on ne peut pas la
reprendre
adama sall france mais non même pas
alors d'un des six dames
non en fait il suffit de se développer
il suffit de se développer on peut jouer
qu'à glisser 6 par exemple à wind
tranquille reste la pièce avant on
laisse la pièce donc en attaque un
cavalier donc là à priori doigt les
recalés prendre cavaliers qui on prend
et problème maintenant un vrai problème
ici est le problème est toujours là donc
après bon j'ai cessé une partie est
alors soit on enlève le soin d'enlever
cavalli si on prend le pion et en
simplifie soit les noires bombers
effectivement récupérer leur pièce parce
qu'on va le laisser élus cavaliers si on
veut enlever le cavalier il ya très peu
de cases active à ces le case actif ce
serait le 4 mai alors là on court à la
catastrophe parce que les câbles des
prix interallié
puis on prend et d'emprunts et d'un
échec à etam échec le fameux regarder
oui parce que sur g3 qui attaquent la
dame up d'un prend 1,4 et chez coran et
et et est évidemment la tourache un
piège classique
voilà qui oblige le roi a bougé par
exemple un f2 est en d2 il s'est passé
pas très bon comme non alors donc voilà
donc luc d'autres possibilités donc plus
classique fou ici c'est le foot pro
réussissent même si c'est prôner 4 doit
être je pense la ligne principale en
général qui est plus souvent je me fous
projet 6 on ne dévie pas de la troisième
partie forgés 6 pouces pas font craindre
qu'ils ont promis je prends je pense que
pions prendre et si on prend des quatre
îles et le coup et vous les jouez le g6
et tranquille et plus classique en
manioc un temps fou et trois peut-être
topalov a peur d'une préparation la
langue aussi possible donc
donc là on reste dans la dans la
troisième partie avec eux c'est prend
des quatre dames pour des cadres ici
fait non c'est plutôt un arc a peut être
peur d'une préparation et topalov du
coup puisqu'ils jouent faux j'ai six au
lieu de prendre des cartes alors qu'il
pourrait il c'est un attaquant on dit
dans les trappeurs oui oui mais
peut-être qu'il n'aime pas cette
variante tout simplement alors fou j'ai
six faux et 3 tranquille donc je défends
n'en connaît ensuite toujours la
troisième partie c'est prendre des
quatre daims prend des quatre d'un
programme et charles or donc ça c'est
important parce qu'on reprend de la dame
en échange elle a donc on est quasiment
déjà tout de suite dans dune
une finale qui a fait l'ena on peut
parler de finale
c'est bon il ya encore beaucoup de
pièces alors c'est toujours délicat de
savoir si ces finales pas finale mais on
est quand même quelque chose qui
ressemble beaucoup à une finale les
thèmes classiques des finales c'est à
dire que c'est moins tactique que
positionne elle est fausse et les pions
qui vont faire la différence
- donc fou prendrait quatre c'est fait
donc cavalier f17 pareil que dans la
troisième on propose un échange de
pièces qui est accepté qu'elle les prend
cavaliers prend des fois il faut prendre
donc là à l'inde continuent à 6 pareil
il suit toujours on va suivre tour c'est
un donc ça c'est logique on a déjà parlé
dans la troisième donc on contrôle a
commencé on va vouloir sans doute avec
les blancs jouer roi depuis ramené notre
tour soit en d1 soir après tour ces deux
ans et un plus même plus certainement de
façon à contrôler la colonne c'est donc
là alors où est le manque crucial ça
c'est important
on l'avait laissé jupes aux données déjà
paraît peut-être dans la nuit une partie
je sais pas mais si on regarde la
position là visuellement elle paraît
quand même très favorables au blond
représente beaucoup d espace isolé dans
l'espace ils ont déjà sorti toutes leurs
pièces quasiment tous pointent alors et
surtout le fou des quatre en fait à
empêche le développement puisqu'on peut
pas sortir le fond à cause de freins g7
et c'est donc en interne vrai qu'on va
perdre encore du temps à se développer
mais y'a pas les dames alors c'est
peut-être moins grave aussi mais on va
quand même comment on se dit ça va pas
être si simple de se développer fessée
ba systems développe on pourrait faire 5
pour boucher food et 4 le problème c'est
que ça laisse une alors si énorme on
désole bien sûr l'asie alors si on fait
aussi évidemment à hambourg et le fou ça
obligera à bouger le fou mais on a un
gros problème c'est la caste des cinq
qui est magnifique pour le cavalier et
qui va menacer des trous 1 ses 7 ans b 6
non certains de jouer c'est pas bon donc
c'est pas simple de trouver un plan pour
le north se développer parce que tant
qu'on peut pas bouger le fouet fuite
avant la tourache 8 ne bouge pas du tout
oui parce que le fait de ne pas sortir
se font non seulement belle mais ce fou
en position extrêmement passive a
uniquement la défense a atteint dans les
blancs qu'ils ont un plan en deux tours
ces deux je ramène le tour je double et
je pénètre et après j'ai des gros
problème et il faut se dépêcher et donc
effectivement le coup qu'on avait situé
très joli par ailleurs petit coup d'act
up voilà ton j'ai vite
simplement je perds un petit temps à
défendre ce pion mais c'est très
important puisque ça libère mon fou qui
a pour se développer soit en c5
éventuellement soit en d6 soir les
quatre bons et je ne recrée pas ce qui
est parfois très embêtant mais là comme
on l'a dit c'est déjà une finale et le
roi sera moins exposée que dans une
poésie donc voilà si je rentre pas mais
on fait les blancs non plus mon par ok
en fait ils vont effectivement les
blancs une fois sorti le fou devant une
belle case pour le roi ans est
difficilement attaquable de la part des
blancs quand même les noirs sont plus
resserrées on le voit bien puisqu'ils
jouent sur 3 yards et 3 3 rangées
celle ci
8 7 et 6 et les blancs sur quatre entre
la 4e 3e seconde provient donc on voit
bien la différence des espaces quatre
rangées contre trois pour les blancs et
donc h4 alors c'est là que hollande va
varier puisque dans la troisième ici la
menace évidemment des blancs c'est de
jouer lâche 5 galles le fou et au lieu
de jouer h6 comme dans la troisième
avant de vous change alors pourquoi il
change ça c'est intéressant h5 parce que
notre fille dans la troisième il s'en
est bien sorti donc pourquoi pourquoi il
change à ce moment là parce qu'il a peur
d'une préparation alors est ce que c'est
je ne sais pas j'ai dans la votre
analyse de la 3d ne sais pas si vous
avez trouvé des ddd des améliorations
significatives non la significative pour
améliorer en allusion aux pressions on a
vu qu'il y avait une pression et un
volet sur les dames bon mais après on
est toujours l'aspect psychologique dû
changer au premier si on sort un peu
l'adversaire de ces préparations enfin
l'aspect psychologique est aussi
purement de préparation oui il a
forcément quelque chose en tête des
achats qui
il doit penser que c'est bon alors fait
nommer qu'eux au premier abord c'est un
coup très très bizarre
oui c'est bizarre parce qu'on me fait
bizarre disons que le problème c'est que
ce pian est définie par le fou et on
voit mal le pion j'ai 6 et 7
tôt ou tard venir angers 6 parce que
vous serez le fou dans ce cas là si
l'éternel 7 alors combien angers 6 pour
protéger ce pion et le fou à plus de
toutes cases il est derrière ses pions
il sert à rien donc on se demande
effectivement le pire aux chocs
il y a une double de dentelle on va dire
aux pions en sachant qu'il est plus
faible torchis s'ils étaient protégés
par des proches inquiets protégé par le
flou qui ce qui mobilise opl fou il est
posé par le fouet et on voit mal la tour
revenir à la fuite
mon enfant est méritée et en plus tu vas
y prends une case où il pense qu'elle
valorise c'est pour ça qu'en général on
met pas les pions sur les cases de ces
footeux c'est que pour éviter que les
points clés fouilles de l'air exactement
donc là dans le sait notre plan c'est
une autre idée et la topaloff
va très bien joué je trouve d'ailleurs
parce que il y met l'accent sur le
problème de cette configuration qui est
classique
c'est une configuration qu'on peut
retrouver dans d'autres par exemple à 44
la quarantaine est un peu la même chose
on a un fou qui a harcelé comme ça etc
sont souvent interrogations jeu plutôt
acheté en joual séisme et j'ai vu une
partie de kasparov
quand ils étaient jeunes en fait où il
avait joué à cinq ils avaient supplié
que c'était peut-être pas mal est tout
sauf qu'il a plus jamais rejoué aurait
alors un tank
mais effectivement le problème regardez
c'est que si on arrive à mettre un
cavalier ici il va attaquer à la fois le
foot et en menacer de prendre mais
pourquoi pas la paire de fou mais
surtout de casser des structures est
complètement voilà on sera obligé de
reprendre du pillon avec 1
une structure pas bonne et puis si le
football c'est le pillage scène qu'ils
ont prises donc en cavale f4 serait
extrêmement pénibles les topalov met
l'accent dessus tout de suite regardé le
coup suivant topalov cavaliers de
tranquille bien jouer il va jouer sur le
problème de cette petite structure j'ai
6 h 5 au lieu de six c'est qu'on peut
pas enlever le fou alors parce que si
cavalière 4,6 c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure si je joue j'ai six pour
remplacer le fou par action alors le
faux c'est totalement un mur in il est
derrière ces puits confie c'est vraiment
le fou inactifs par excellence est donc
ce cavalier en f4 menace de déstructurer
et de prendre le pion à 100 s'il nous
faut bouge donc très gros problème pour
les noirs donc sa force du coup suivant
quasiment food et si ce salaire
suffisant aussi en ans avait dû dans le
calcul est fou des six évidemment tac et
bien empêche cavaliers f4 tout de suite
mais topalov insiste avec de très jolis
coups suivants aussi fou et 3 voilà donc
il a fini le travail sur g7 et
maintenant il vient protéger la kdf 4 il
vous jouez krief 4 et si les noirs
évidement prennent ce cavalier ce qui
sera quasiment forcé s'il n'y a pas de
possibilité d'empêcher sa et donc parce
que sinon soit on casse la structure
noir avec de gros gros soucis de
structure soit on prend le casting sur x
11,7 donc il faut empêcher qu'elle est
faible donc si on prend du fou mais on a
la paire de fruits la paire de flou avec
un fou qui contrôle la case c7 qui calme
et très importante parce que 37 se fout
contrôlerait a cassé cette avec la tour
qui est des gens c'est un ses avions
pourraient venir ans et 7 et après le
roi un rêve de la deuxième tour en c1 on
contrôler totalement la colonne et on va
gagner
la partie je pense ça va être très très
difficile à défendre donc danger quand
même pour un an delà le plomb topaloff
est très simple mais effectivement on
l'a dit dès le début à chaque le
problème de la chance et se fout il
s'appuie sur une couleur elle cazorla la
case f4 et topalov se ruent vraiment sur
ce plan c'est à dire premier coup
cavalier e 2 full aux trois-ponts
applicable henri iv je sais pas s'il
aurait pu prendre son temps peut-être
parce que le problème de la position
nord c'est qu'elle est très très
resserrée et on ne sait pas trop ce
qu'ils vous ont à faire comme cool qu'il
est ce que le fouet des 4000 da ilha
d'autres avantages et il est très bien
placé il pointe sur j'essaie de toujours
oui et peut-être qu'on aurait pu déjà
préparé un peu en laissant le front des
4es jouer je ne sais pas moi quelque
chose comme aura évident de f2 sentir
les tours attendre de voir ce que ce que
tu penses que le plan que joue ta vraie
trop rapide en fait je ne sais pas mais
ça paraît trop simple
connaissant la chose peut-être qu'on
pourrait améliorer leur connaissons la
suite de la partie topalov va facilement
à échanger la tour c en est qu'il est
reprise par un fou en fout c'est un psy
quant à nombre reprenait en c1 avec s'il
reprenait avec une tournée tant que le
fou ce serait sûrement beaucoup plus
fort et bon il faudrait rien et meoli
tout foule 3 tout de suite peut-être
qu'on peut préparer avant et jouer un
roi f2 attendre de voir ce que font les
blancs et alors on va voir mais en tout
cas non mais alors le coup si en allant
est très intéressant par contre parce
que il va empêcher en quelque sorte
les choses par un joli coup je trouve
centrale cac valeo 5 km c'est alors
l'intérieur carlos est maintenant c'est
que le bon on va évidemment n'empêche
pas qualif 4 d'ailleurs c'est ce que
fait aux palois mais c'est que ce
cavalier il a un double intérêt c'est
que là ils attaquent le fou c4 dont qui
permet d'éventuellement abeilles de
compenser la perte de la paire de fou
par par un autre fou et puis de bombay
il peut aussi reprendre en justice par
le cavalier maintenant il aura donné la
paire de fou effectivement voilà mais
voilà donc la c1 en deux
de jouer juste après se secoue câble et
f4 et il joue évidemment tour s'est vite
voilà donc pour ces huit là l'intérêt
c'est que si les blancs près d'angers
s'ils sont peu un fait prendre dans ces
quatre et non pas et non pas reprendre
le cavalier j 6 imaginons par exemple
que les six cavaliers pranger
sinistrement donc là c'est une
réfutation tactique en fait finalement
du plan c'est pas tellement
positionnelle cet acte i on a repris la
longue finalement quand il se passe
maintenant
bon sans doute le cavalier va revenir on
peut aussi entendre tv3 remarque
d'autant tb3 mais on peut jouer cavalier
des six mois on n'a pas peur puisque les
tours sont attaqués ans il faut prendre
cavaliers il ya tout reprendre pour
échelle donc voila et on a un problème
toujours le cas légers 6 donc là c'était
jouable ça offre c'était jouable pour
qui exactement cavaliers projet si c'est
quand même embêtant effectivement on n'a
pas envie de laisser souvent ces quatre
peut-être tout reprend ses quatre
étaient d'ailleurs plus fort c'est être
repensée 4 est plus fort ici qu'à
l'étranger si alors on fait la variante
ici tour c'est 8 alors cavaler précise
quand même et tour prince et quatre sont
encore plus forts effectivement puisque
ça attaque la tour c'est un bon elle est
défendue mais l attaque
oui mais en cas de prix ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'en cas de prise du careï
ici la tournée plus défendu et on prend
d'abord la tour avec échec qui
empruntent cavalli
on égalise la position autour du cou ya
plus que les tours fou donc ça c'est
bien ça aussi ça c'était correct donc
c'est pourquoi en fait sur tours s'est
vite
topalov je vous fous b3 tout simplement
wolof il a débloqué cherche à gagner ils
peuvent alors entrer dans de belles
choses voilà ce serait totalement
annulant donc là à n'en profitent déjà
pour échanger cette tour donc
l'avantagent suite grâce à cette
manoeuvre un peu tactique de cavaillon
simple c'est que les changes une paire
de tours ici et surtout bon mais il
apaise l'attention sur la colonne c'est
qui va un peu le libérer pour pour faire
autre chose donc france et un fort c est
maintenant recettes alors il donne la
paire de foule il n'y a pas le choix
c'est pour ça que au tout à l'heure je
disais fou procès un bon il sas
oui s'il avait jours aux doigts ça c'est
avec deux avant que ça c'est la rupture
reprendre de la tout ça c'est un petit
peu amélioré quelque part pour pour les
noirs parce que voilà il jouera aux 7
finalement la tour blanche et pas plus
active que la tour que la tournoi
rencontré un ton noir d'un coup elle va
arriver sur la bonne colonne qui est
c'est bon elle est où cette problèmes de
structure là on a toujours ce problème
ici bien sûr mais on va donner un
garde-fou mais n'empêche que les noirs
ont activé leurs pièces et que c'est
vrai c'est pas si clair alors que alors
que oui que encore effet les noirs
sicile et blanc a pris un peu plus de
temps et avait joué par exemple en euro
f2 au départ au départ de la variante
ski témérité des tours question de cette
voie vers l'ue sera peut-être plus tard
sera peut-être plus tard dans le match
mais c'est ça parce que c'est l'intérêt
de match ou si c'est ça va plus ça peut
l'avantager marge par rapport à un
tournoi on doit une partie tout c'est
que dans un match où les joueurs ont
retravaillé souvent les mêmes
partis pour mettre l'accent au largue et
des problèmes donc 3 2 donc
effectivement s'il avait joué plutôt à
deux ou trois eph 2 mais on aurait pu
envisager sur ton protocole utilisé tout
reprendre ton de la part des blancs avec
une tourte déjà placé sur la colonne
c'est ce qui n'est pas le cas ce qui
permet au noir de prendre cette colonne
direct donc la voilà donc là les noirs
effectivement bon mais ils peuvent
donner un père de fou mais notre camp
lorrain de facteurs annulant quand même
dans ce type de finale c'est qu'on a
deux pions qu'entre 2006 et quatre pions
ici contre 4 donc c'est une structure
parfaitement symétrique
ce sont les plus durs à gagner à une
structure symétrique et non on ne peut
plus facilement gagner des parties où il
ya un déséquilibre de pion à la gauche
la finale dames - les droits puisque
grâce à ce déséquilibre on va attirer
les pièces d'un côté pour éventuellement
après contre-attaqué de l'autre alors
que de concéder deux côtés comme ça
c'est très difficile et puis je n'ai pas
si ouverte le savez si on a perdu
fousseret avant un énorme avantage
surtout il ya des calmes des pions des
deux côtés oui un fou ça peut jouer des
deux côtés en même temps un cavalier une
fois qu'il ya d'un côté il y les places
pas très vite et donc effectivement les
la position est quand même encore
préférable pour les blancs même si on a
l'impression déjà un peu plus d'aces
part toujours et cette paire de fou qui
va tomber puisque le fou ne peut pas
partir un jour le problème de choisir
entre la paire de fou
où la structure enfin il ya toujours ce
ça ouais c'est fou j'ai six personnes
qui sont un peu problématique voilà
apparemment hollande a jugé que ce
n'était pas grave alors fou des deux
donc là on voit donc les blancs sont
obligés de repères du temps il faut des
deux pour libérer leur tour h 1 ils vont
sans doute vouloir venir en c1 et la
très jolie coup alors là on arrive à un
moment crucial de la partie puisque la
la menace des blancs existe c'est de
jouer il faut de foot c'est pousser 3
par exemple
c'est une vraie menace parce que
imaginons que les noirs jouent aux
attentes en alliant la tour ces sept
bons fous ces trois pourquoi pousser 3
est embêtant puisque la menace c'est fou
prendre cavaliers vous rend fou et
cavaliers pranger 6 casse la structure
ou même cavalier prend directement
j'avais pour cavaler prend avec
évidemment mais surtout des fois on sera
obligé d'en ramener le roi et suite ici
par exemple
non plutôt que de faire [ __ ] on vous
prend vous prend cavaliers ici ouais
mais les prend là maintenant pardon vous
c'est trop a dû dire oui oui oui le roi
f8 pourra pour être protégé g7 sinon qu
à l epr en cavale et prendre tout projet
c'est d'accord mais là c'est vraiment
très peiné parce qu'elle a tourné en d1
le fou malade sont maintenant bien des 1
voilà et c'est donc cccp n'y viennent
vraies menaces viennent vraie menace est
là anondo rejoue le trouble le coût de
la partie on peut on peut dire un
magnifique bas on se demande un peu
comment il va vraiment c'est parce qu'il
a des problèmes je faisais trois fous
ces trois qu'une vraie
ces 3 suivent et autour des 1 il ya des
menaces il ya des menaces de pour casser
la structure à dewerdt pour la pression
existe ces deux fous sont braqués sur
les pions le cavalier est en pression
maximale sur geci sur scène on peut
envisager plein de possibilité de
prendre un petit avantage non
négligeable en finale et donc qu'il faut
absolument réagir et un autre où une
très belle parade
très jolie qui va forcer les gens à
prendre décision f6 magnifique on
pourrait mettre presque un point
d'exclamation ou deux sur ce coup
pourquoi on n'avait pas ce que c'est un
sacrifice positionnelle pourquoi
sacrifices et veut parce que regarder le
pion aussi cette emprise
alors pourquoi on joue et 6 à
l'ordinaire faut comprendre pourquoi ici
c'est parce qu'il suffit pas de dire on
se sacrifie un pion pour que ça soit
groupe met en joue et 6 passes qu'on
libère le fuji 6 en hausse entre
guillemets fouet f7 effectivement à
lefaux est parti il protège aussi ce et
h5 est protégé et le fou n'est plus sous
la menace du cavalier donc on a résolu
tous nos problèmes on raisonne une bonne
partie des problèmes le fourbe va
rejouer on va pouvoir jouer on va
pouvoir consolider la position fais
beaucoup de malaises sont possibles avec
le plan c'est clairement fou au fc
missiles et les noirs et les blancs font
rien de spécial on peut être sûr que
s'il faut vous avez cette vaste maison
alors c'est tout à fait magnifique alors
qu'est ce qui se passe si les blancs
prennent le pion de 6 parce que c'est ça
le problème le problème c'est qu'on peut
prendre elles mêmes de deux façons de la
lente
imaginons cavaliers prendre 6 ab dans ce
cas là c'est simple on regarde et on
joue faux et 7 et là on a un problème
puisque le cavalier ici hop
protège aussi la prise du four b3 pour
l'instant qui les ans le 6 mai si il
sort le fou le pire alors le seul coup
c'est qu'ils avaient avalé des 4 et la
serre protège à la comprend et après la
reprise simplement tour ces deux et les
noirs son actif elle le fou d2 et cloud
et on menace de prendre b2 et si par
exemple tour b1 pour protéger le pion et
bien on peut jouer cavalier calais c4 et
là c est menacée toujours b2c b2b perdu
il a les noirs ont même le ont même pris
le dessus avec revenir le public à
devenir hk très faible puisqu'il est de
la couleur du foulon gravé sur le fuji 3
on a beaucoup de mal à protéger ce pion
donc effectivement ça peut ça peut se
retourner donc voyez le problème de ce
coup là de cavaliers prendre 6 donc pas
de possibilité alors
voilà ce rêve 6 voilà donc là on vient
de voir cavaler prendre on peut faire
[ __ ] on on peut faire deuxième option
donc il fallait voir fou prend alors là
ça a l'air très fort puisque en plus le
fou attaque la tour s'est vite mais
c'est la même chose en cette troisième
fois nous protège tous les cas ces deux
et donc on joue simplement pour ses
tours ses deux en fait dans les deux cas
c'est exactement la même manoeuvre si
c'est la même enseigne
dès qu'on va prendre aux 6 on va plus ou
moins obligé avec les plans de lâcher la
case c2 et la casse et 2 est très
importante parce que la tour à tour peut
peut s'y engouffrer menaces et b2
menacée
lassé des tas de choses oui parce qu'en
plus il ya des menaces de cavale et ses
quatre et ans regardez il ya une autre
menace aussi c'est que si les blanches
b3 regardez on joue simplement cavaliers
c6 et la menaçait les quoi de faire
[ __ ] et en cavalier faut près en fou
et roy prend fou des 5
on n'a aucun le cavalier g6 toujours en
l'air mais alors sur calais projet si ce
chèque simplement on prend le fou et
ici on a toujours des menaces de venir
en d4 ici attaqué le pion b3 on a
toujours des problèmes fait la tour
noire est très active et non puis les
grosses je sais pas ce qu'on fait parce
que le cavalier ou cali et 6 n'a plus de
caisses de sortie n'a pas 40 peugeot à
detroit on peut jour à detroit qui
entreprend le chou et attaquer cavalli
on peut prendre les deux est absurde roi
prend simplement regarder roef 7 et le
cavalier pris au piège booba lecavalier
regardez ici ici ici ici c'est prix et
s'il va ensuite d'abord il est mal placé
et ont simplement je vous crois j'ai
vite et si revient maintenant que jouera
le 7 et ça y est les prix voyez par des
cons on le poursuit
ce cavalier ça y est peu plus il opte
aucune case n'est permise
et donc on a deux pièces contre une tour
tokyo est rien c'est probablement pas
simple du tout quant à juger mais ses
projets ont des devoirs qui vont essayer
de jouer pour lire les noirs c'est de
jouer pour le gagner d'autant que le
pion hk très faible et on va pouvoir
peut-être créer un pion passé de ce côté
donc en tout cas il ya du jeu faire
attention parce qu'une tour peut aussi
s'avérer forte mais évidemment c'est
toujours mieux d'avoir les deux pièces
de son côté donc sur m6 finalement mais
ces deux prises n'ont pas plu à topalov
c'était donc bien vu d'un mandat la
menace c'est de jouer il faut s est donc
finalement on prend le fou juste à temps
avant qu'ils ne s'échappent
donc l'idée à chaque fois c'était
vraiment l'activité et l'entrée de la
tour c de la tour sur la case c2 qui qui
compense parfaitement
donc c'est honteux pas l'homme joue de
façon simple entre guillemets il prend
la paire de soul tout simplement et il
garde ses deux fous qui contrôlent ce
contrôle très bien l'échiquier alors
sacrifice maintenant alors évidemment
les gan menace nous fait une menace
il ya la menace ne jouer
cavalier f4 riche l attaquant gedo
forçant des coups qu'on leur enlève deux
qui sont pas forcément de plaisance
puisqu'il ya cavaliers detroit et échecs
et attaque le plonger de aussi et là il
trouve une très jolie couteau palenfo si
j'ai trois millions lors de toute façon
c'était utile parce que on ressent bien
que topalov il a pas envie de laisser sa
tour mais oui parce que là le careï g6
attaque le pion h4 donc si on laisse la
torrent à chiens et selectour qui va
s'activer
donc on a envie de protéger ce pion quoi
qu'il arrive et on trouve heureusement
qu'ils trouvent se courbent si le roi
noir est 1er set il peut pas on ne peut
pas jouer ce coup effectivement alors
donc là ce coup là c'est juste basée sur
l'enfilade si le foot pro pourquoi je
dis c'est le roi n'en à rien parce que
si les noirs garder prennent ici
hop un jour en fait tour g1 et dès que
le football c'est le cavalier perdu mais
si le roi était là il aurait protégé le
cavalier effectivement donc c'est ça
tient à peu de chose mais on peut jouer
ce coup et l'idée de topalov évidemment
c'est de protéger h4 donc de libérer la
sa tour qui pour l'instant est
uniquement défenseur du bien et puis il
va sans doute contrôler
cette défense en jouant f4 qui va aussi
annihiler la pression du food et 6 / g 3
puisque les noirs quand même menace de
sortir leurs cavaliers d'attaqué
réellement ce pion donc j'ai trois
cavaliers ou 5 f 4 quand même voilà donc
là j'ai une structure solide puisque le
fou va buter contre le pied en f4 une
structure solide et puis voyez où je
sais pas trop où on voit le pion à la
faiblesse du pur à chengdu peut-être se
révéler peut-être qu'un jour ce plan là
ce plan est un peu fait elle aussi
puisque on voit bien sûr food et un taux
ou tard bon mais on pourra encore jouer
ici c'est bien sûr mais ça voudrait dire
mettre tous ses pions sur les taches
blanches et les foules et les noirs
qu'ils défendent non plus de foot case
blanche
c'est pas simple paf simple à tenir tout
à fait tout à fait donc là qu'avaient
laissé six menace cavale et des cartes
et chèques dans une pièce alors il faut
faire quelque chose donc là topalov
évidemment le voit cette menace alors là
on va dire il ya un côté un peu triste
pour topalov parce que il a joué toute
cette partie moment où est vraiment la
chose qui l'a qu'il a obtenu alors il ya
certes le purin de le pion à chaque oeil
à la paire de fou surtout les lactaires
de fond qui avale ses 6 on a
l'impression que le cavalier très très
actif et qu'il va falloir séparée du
père de foucauld intérimaire est parce
que il et on va voir qu'il est très
actif et il faut empêcher cavaliers des
quatre on peut pas enlever décemment le
fou en d1 ce cahier des quatre quand
même échec et on a des problèmes tout de
suite
donc il joue la taupe à la fin pourquoi
quand je jouais foudre mais sûr mais si
tu sais pas si c'est très très passif
d'attendre achats ne bouge plus ouais je
ne bouge pas bon de jouer après roy
détroit et c est que ce fou attaque ici
bien sûr donc voila c'était un plan
quand même possible pour mettre au pas
la officie choisi de jouer sous ses
trois meilleurs plus étroit évidemment
rend la paire de fous fous ces trois on
contrôle la case des quatre empêche
camedescasse bien sûr mais par contre b4
c'est ainsi que les échanges des fous et
forcée voilà le fond d'appeler des
secours se retirait pour fou n'a plus de
gaz donc on va échanger là le fou donc
on n'a plus qu'une finale sous contre
cavaliers alors attention parce que le
fonds peut quand même s'avérer le fou
plein de cartes blanches supérieur aux
cavaliers dans certaines variantes
le problème c'est toujours ce pion
motion qui voit là sur une case blanche
qui va être pas simple mais on a encore
une petite faiblesse ici donc on va voir
faut prendre les quatre échecs comme
elle prend le cas est tournée tout pas
officié comme de jouer pour quelque
chose pour le gabon il sur sa tour qu'il
aurait on ne peut pas essayer d'échanger
les tours je pense pas s'il veut gagner
il faut vraiment faire quelque chose de
plus le plus actif
s'il y aurait un plan genre des deux
tours c'est en est fou d un pour essayer
mais voilà c'est qu'il peut pas trop
bouger son poupe hamas il essaie
d'attaquer h5
évidence il n'y a même pas sa tour
d'abord il ya tour ces quatre attaques
le point 4 attaques potentielles
je pensais plus animée avec d'abord au
roi des deux tours c'est un des
meilleurs l'avait jamais on peut gagner
il ya des échecs possible et on sait pas
où on va c'est très difficile c'est
complètement
c'est très dur il est bon pour des
appareils écologiques autour des 1 est
logique voilà tour des uns est logique
il veut sans doute activer sa tour un
des 4 et ensuite peut-être jouer il faut
dire il veut quand même il va vouloir
attaquer ce pion à 5 c sur leur cas a
laissé six donc l' empêche pour des cas
comme ça c'est réglé
et là aussi c'est un joli coup parce
qu'enfin mignon mais il y a toujours la
case de parler personne qui paie ni bien
sûr mais oui parce qu'au bal fou car les
a5 le fou n'a pas de gaz or que la deux
il peut aller que en a deux dans ce cas
tour ces deux échecs alors on peut
imaginer un cavalier regarder qui vient
ici le four n'a pas de cazin cedria la
tombe
et s'il nous faut vieira 2 c'est tour
ces deux échecs au un pénible
donc effectivement qu'elle sait si ces
jolies pénibles a d'ailleurs rien c'est
très peu donc ça explique le coup
suivant topalov mais qui écrit
simplement tour des deux voies la tour
d2 voilà comme ça je contrôle la
deuxième et j'ai moins peur de keyria
éventuellement je jouerai mon fondé
voilà et maintenant je peux envisager
puisque le cas payet ans et 6 je peux
envisager food est un qui garde un oeil
sur eux et surtout qui va attaquer le
pion à celle non pas d'ici là
donc une fois qu'on aura sorti le roi et
si les noirs sont bidouillées 6 on
pourrait même envisager les siècles et
souvent ça parce que si on fait sauter
ce pion tout en ayant dévié le plonger
on aura un pion passé et là c'est plus
la même effectivement et puis en plus de
toutes façons positionnement on va dire
aussi si on oblige les noirs a empilé
toutes leurs pièces tous leurs pions
pardon sur les cases blanches à mais là
c'est bon c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
eux parce qu'ils ont tous bien sûr un
fou de cases blanches sont si mauvais
donc là on y prend les grands moyens
altro un coup
pêchue surprenant sur trois ans j'ai
cinq coupes et chute d'un homme
dangereux puisque l'on l'a annoncé la
pression maximale ici bas du côté les
droits il veut en fait profité du fait
que la tour est passé devant le roi en
fait c'est ça l'idée pour ouvrir la
colonne j'ai proposé en tout cas
l'ouvrir la colonne des salaires par
exemple sur si les noir et blanc joue un
coup comme h prend ici
f prend et puis
roy je sais pas - le roi ici simplement
les noirs peuvent activer leur tour et
autres possibilités c'est que les noirs
imaginons que les blanches beaucoup
c'est pas moins beaucoup comme fou d un
n'importe quoi l'idée ça peut être aussi
de d'échanger et de se mettre en g8
même si saleh sa gestion faible à une
autre idée et qu'on va voir comment on
va faire aussi ces deux bouchers g4
comme ça à 5 est en partie protégé mais
il pourrait être attaqué par l'arrière
plus tard cc oui voilà c'est très
générale ce que je dis mais bon j'ai
placé un coup qui complique g5 ccc
c'est un cookie qui pose plein de
questions pour la suite ce qui pose une
question en tout cas piqué affaiblissant
quand même pour les poulets nord mais on
voit aussi que pour les blancs c'est pas
clair
donc là topalov à trouver ce qu'on
suivant le coup droit et faisait
simplement donc transmettant à f2 ont
déjà il évite les problèmes qui avaient
la base de qualité dont un bon ça c'est
une première chose ensuite en venant
d'eux mêmes en cas de prises 14 et 4 un
coup comme tour g8 table dans l'eau on
pourra pas pénétrer sur l'écologie mais
on peut envisager on pourra pas
envisager de venir angers 4 puisque
voilà maintenant qu'on a joué 9 2 il ya
aussi la menace fou d un attaque à cinq
oui la caisse dit revenons une bonne
bonne chose pour le oui et oui parce
qu'il continuera à protéger à 4 tout en
tapant sur st et donc là bas on trouve
une solution positionnelle g4 voilà donc
là c'est réglé terminez en bouche
en fait maintenant tourner toutes les
possibilités des changes sont sont
étouffés et on a verrouillé 7,7 colonna
donc là un fou ici tu après contre du
béton et donc pourrait pas faire grand
chose
alors si vous aimez ça pose un problème
c'est que sinon on imagine un fan de
final un fou qui se placerait la et
effectivement c'est un nombre ont pilé
ses pions sur les pièces blanches aux
couleurs du fou et puis le pion à chiens
qui est maintenant vraiment très très
faible et je l'aurai où on voit une tour
sur la 5e et
oui mais la wintour qui viendra mais
pour l'instant pas sa dose rennes peut
pas rester en place c'est à dire qu'il
joue sur le fait à lanzhou le fei a
ainsi manqué ne serait ce qu un pion au
centre le pire ce serait plus grave mais
le fait que la position est encore assez
bouché que les noirs ici avec le roi de
7 et les pions aussi sepsis ici contrôle
pas toutes les cases de pénétration et
même le cavaly c6 fait que tout ça est
est verrouillé on peut pas passer voilà
tout ça et tout ça est parfaitement
contrôlé par les noirs regardez donc
c'est très difficile pour les blancs
maintenant d'envisager des choses alors
ce que pourrait envisager les blancs
c'est de jouer ce qu fait d'ailleurs
topalov tour ces deux avec l'idée tour
c'est celle qu'elle est je ramasse et
bien il ya doute sur la faiblesse on va
dire effectivement c'est la cinquième en
plus avec un clouage de cavaillé quelque
part parce que la tour derrière alors
qu'on peut envisager cavaliers as à 7
mai le fou va s'avérer beaucoup plus
fort que le cahier puisque air défiant
sur blanc ici appuyant sur blanc là ça
fait beaucoup
donc le roi noir devra rester ici pour
empêcher une pénétration du fou surtout
que ça m'aiderait le câble et sur une
case entrée facile
une casse pas si bon il pourra toujours
ce qui va primer ça va être difficile
quoi ça risque d'être difficile
donc là on joue autour des 8 heures ça
c'est malin contre attaque sur tours c5
tourer chèque très certainement la
possibilité c'est de faire tourner et
trans lui l'actif sa tour il a pas envie
de bouger sans qu'il y ait pour le
moment de chasse on ne peut pas on a dit
qu'il était cloué donc regarder ce qu'on
vendait ce qui se passe dans ce retour
c'est simple ça prend quand même un pion
important autour c56 même gros avantage
noir en fait retournés deux échecs en
moi j'ai trois ans on prend b2 0 1 mais
2 avec attaque du fou voire voir voir
voire peut-être aller chercher j'ai
d'ailleurs
plutôt de prendre b2 oui on peut même
jouer tour j'ai deux menaces tout
reproche et 3 suivi du ramassage ici il
n'ya pas de moi une fois qu'on est roger
ii il ya pas moyen de protéger ce piola
donc voilà donc il faut pas jouer ça il
faut surtout pas jouer ça il faut pas
laisser les noires s'activent et
s'explique le coup suivant whaou 3 en
hongrois 3 voilà donc l'agent pêche
toute pénétration et je menace toujours
tous ces cinq tous ces cinq avec
pression le latéral pénible de ce côté
là et la belle allemande finira bien phu
en fait il n'ya pas encore énormément de
menaces
blanchard si la menace c'est tour ces
cinq là on va voir dans la partie qui en
fait surtout ses 5 il a prévu une
manoeuvre assez efficace alors tour des
six donc il va tomber
ils attendent attendent pour ses 5 voilà
l topalov vienne et durban mais ok tour
des six sert à rien on a mis j'attaque
as tu fais mes réponses d'un land aussi
sec
calvet il faut laisser quelque chose que
tu choisis voilà un an
c'est simple menace tome des trois
échecs et de le fou voilà le fou et puis
en plus on voit bien derrière aussi
aussi le plan g3 donc donc il faut faire
quelque chose pour protéger ce chou et
là c'est pas si simple tour c'est cet
échec
alors ça c'est malin l'idée borgo ca
vendent parce qu'en fait on veut revenir
en c3 pour empêcher les chèques mais au
passage c'est toujours bien il éloigne
le winglois réfection des opérations on
en croit des huit forcer un bon
quasi-fonds touché 3 et on revient en c3
pour empêcher cette manoeuvre de
pénétrer victime le coût prévu par
topalov pour défendre s'étaient tour ces
trois là mais il avait profité avant
pour éloigner un peu le roi noir et
mettre la pression parole sur le pur
aussi ce qui n'est plus protégé que par
la tour voilà et la hollande revient de
set et finalement il dit à topalov tu
vois en fait je peux même pas passé en
fait c'est ça c'est une forteresse
forteresse dynamique topaloff
enfin non de oui oui
les recettes pièces relativement bien
passée il a while i'm une faiblesse mais
une faiblesse c'est comme on dit souvent
pour gagner une partie dont il faut
qu'il y en ait deux fois car les deux
pour faire pour faire diversion
une pour attaquer et l'autre pour faire
diversion donc ici quand même tenté un
truc alors ce faisant ils ont eu cinq
évident ce faisant 5
bush quelque part aussi la faiblesse
acheter un confort donc voilà que soit
le positionnement de trucs qu'on voit
tout de suite c'est que on met les pieds
sur noir alors mais l'émission surnomme
c'est vraiment ça va effectivement
boucher le chemin jusqu'à la surface
et puis en plus on laisse la case fc
rock libre
cette case là oui mais il ya un fouet
pour un cavalier aride accord pour
acquérir on voit bien vu la structure
noir on pourrait passer par là par là et
hop venir ici attaqué puis angers 3 et
j'ai donc cherché un peu long il faut il
faut du temps pour le faire ouais mais
tu as raison c'est pénible donc tour 17
de la part d'un homme qui lui sont pour
se presse pas de reprendre
topalov f6 3.96 est effectivement
maintenant qu'on a repris du roi ici là
on voit bien comme ça que la 9-5 bon ben
si on aime cavale et là on n'en a même
pas de souci s'est défendue par le
bouillon dans le roi il sera bien de
cavaillé puisqu'il fera pression sur g3
ce qui va contrebalancer en fait
finalement la faiblesse des pions noire
sépia noir seront tous sur quatre
blanche
bizarrement c est qu on me dit qu'il
faut jamais la télé pions sur le combat
de trois heures c'est ce que puis avant
évidemment c'est salutaire puisque
finalement ses pions quelque part belle
sont bien défendus et contrecarre la
contre pas contre car l'action du fou je
re munich où je suis tombé ou donc donc
effectivement là ça commence à s'aplatir
un peu hein
topalov n'a vraiment pas grand chose
voilà des filets encore technique la
finale mais ya pas de plus en plus il
n'y a pas de voie là les tours s'il est
fou car les s'annulent on va dire que la
position est archi nîmes sa 6ième à
s'échanger alors on va avoir droit aux
deux en croire quelques coups dont clara
2 permet de bombay sa défense g3 parlato
moi je sais pas si c'est très efficace
efficace qu'à laisser 6 voilà on voit la
manoeuvre d'abandon alors il va pouvoir
passer soit par des quatre avec échec
soit pas recette
et pour revenir sur cette fameuse cosef
scène que tu me cites et revin pour
éviter qu'il y ait des quatre échecs car
il est 4 quand même fou des vins et ça y
est on a besoin d'être là mais on voit
bien le coup d'un angle pourquoi g4 est
utile moi ça y est on le voit mais non
un tranquille et l'a simplement regarder
très joli coup d'un de positionner à 5
voilà ça c'est bien pourquoi mais on met
un pion sur noir voilà ça y est enfin on
commence à mes 2 73 et ce qui empêche
d'avoir des pions vissé sur casse
blanche évident si tous les persos sur
leur suffira de mettre la 3d 6 et il est
impossible pour le fou d'attaquer ses
pions voilà et c'est bien au contraire
ce fou même but contre ses propres pions
et on voit d'ailleurs que le fou il
reste à la défense du pion à 4 qui à
tout moment pour être attaquer les noirs
mais vous pourriez envisager des tours
des quatre attaquants le pion et c'est
pour ça qu'il va falloir donc garder se
fout là sans doute on voit que le full
ayant là dans cette situation est dominé
par le cavalière et appliquer et
contrôler toutes les cases dont il peut
s'échanger mai mais il est pas il est
pas meilleure donc pour ces cinq
attaques le pion à 5 et la regarder
coûts intermédiaires en fait cavalier
pts 5
abstract c'était le plan prévu depuis un
bouton l a bien vu que dès que mon livre
est kazem ça qu'on a envie d'y aller un
peu ce que c'était que j'ai trop allégé
trois autos pas joué en f2 parce que
évidemment le fou des uns étant prise du
de la tour donc le seul coup c'est de
ramener la tour en défense avec des mots
et là on a même l'impression que c'est
les doigts qui choisissent ce qu'ils
peuvent jouer un peu au civl away c'est
vrai ouais parce que l'on aurait pu
jouer autour des cathos b4 peut-être
pour forcer les blancs à jouer mais
trois des choses comme ça la plèbe on
sait qui on est quand même des
faiblesses bon il s'est sûrement
ralliement égal mais visuellement on
préfère les limites les noirs parce que
ce qui a valu au restaurant qui est
magnifique la g3 qui est vraiment bien
sûr attaque attaque c'est vraiment
faible et à tout moment les blancs
peuvent menacer les chanter un de toute
façon donc ça paraît pas non plus
absolument
on va avoir quelques coups simplement
les joueurs ici on répétait la position
c'est très difficile on le voit de
passer maintenant l'avantagé des bleus
c'est une bonne nuit si une lentille
tenté qu'il y avait un avantage à laver
y'en a pas vraiment eu car les dca tour
ces cinq cavaliers f5 pour ces trois
répétitions d'une répétition coups de
feu sont partis sûrement ce qu'il ya de
mieux à faire pour les blancs ça devient
instructif cette partie c'est une jolie
partie entre guillemets enfin entre
guillemets part entre guillemets c'est
une jeune femme le le coup d'attendre
quand ils commencent à changer c'est à
chaque tour est très très mystérieux au
départ on se demande qu'est-ce qui
qu'est ce qu'il a vu bon on peut on se
fait pas de souci pour lui c'était
forcément un bon coup parce que oui
c'est la partie c'est là il a répété la
partie d'avant juste jusqu'à ce coup là
qui a forcément analysés à la maison
avec ses seconds en bien sûr c'est le
fruit de la réflexion d'une longue
réflexion a priori ce n'est pas trop de
risques pour soi un mauvais coup et tout
s'éclaire quand on voit finalement m6 le
prix
on va revoir ce coup ci sans doute le
couple est effectivement de la partie
alors je vais essayer de retrouver parce
que c'est forcé un peu au début c'est un
peu plus loin ce point f6 alors tour
c'est un ici voilà on voit voilà ici ce
serait magnifique
alors si on a une position ou juste
juste avant et si on a toujours les
problèmes qu'on avait anticipé depuis le
début ce qu'ils avaient dans l'afrique a
depuis rejoint ce jour-là ce problème de
h5 qui oblige le fou à rester là dont 4
est sous la menace permanente du
cavalier avec menace de football trois
toute manière on en a parlé
magnifique coup quitte les deux on a vu
que les deux prises en un si c'était pas
bonne
as monaco fc nantes oblige et blanc ait
changé c'est le couple est de la partie
c'est le goût donc je pense que c'est le
coût que deux issues de la préparation
d'un homme qui est je peux jouer à
chaque parce que donc il a joué à chaud
qu'au 15e coup c'est ça parce qu'il
avait prévu que sept coups plus tard il
pouvait jouer même si c est cette
manoeuvre qui fait que le bureau si ce
n'est pas prenable parce qu'il ya trop
de cons portatif voilà il faut bien
comprendre un final à cette histoire de
faiblesse qu'il faut pas sous-estimer
évidemment les bons joueurs vont mettre
l'accent sur les faiblesses donc faire
très attention
belle partie alors à nantes mène
toujours dans la queue
ah non point de mon opération pour lui
avec les noix bonne opération pour lui
encore
c'est une position au départ on a un peu
peur pour lui c'est à dire
visuellement on se dit les blancs font
un petit peu mieux mais avec son style
le félin il arrive qu'entre les gars
alors il est bien placé puisque sixième
partie il va jouer avec les blancs et la
7e aussi puisque l'on sera à mi match et
donc des six premières parties étant
passé le match étant 12 alors de la
deuxième moitié du match en fait à
nantes va jouer de nouveau avec les
pièces blanches ans 7e donc sixièmes
avec les blancs 7e en l'annulant pour
inverser les couleurs de la première
partie du match auto pas l'alphabet
démarre avec les blancs et un angle
démarre à la deuxième partie du match
avec les blancs oui surtout que pour
londres avec les blancs il est à 100%
oui bah oui il a donc oui mais
effectivement vite donc on peut être
assez on peut espérer pas mal de cette
de cette sixième partie oui tout à fait
on se retrouve jean je crois la 6e très
bien voilà donc à la sixième
on va voir comment on va essayer de
pourquoi pas marquer son troisième point
il n'y a pas de raison
bon championnat du monde belle partie
technique un bon
il faut analyser ces histoires de
faiblesse et de ce magnifique coin f6
que j'aurais été incapable de trouver
merci jean jacques hy merci stéphane à
bientôt à bientôt